what are you thinking for your thesis
exhibition I'm hoping that it invites
the viewer to look closer at the emotion
that's not typically yeah we're not
noticing emotion let's jump in the deep
end this you can I see what you're doing
cool I like this a lot
so my roommates and I are having a party
tonight woman oh look at you hot staff
meeting someone special there's this guy
I don't even know if these interviews
Hey
I actually feel like I might be moving
away from painting thank you so good are
you sure that you said no and that he
heard you
you told me you've said wait
how much did you have to drink Noel
something Salar happen our friends
she told the school they told her she
was crazy I mean you just say you're
sorry
did you see Luke last night yeah how
long did you stay don't let it ruin the
rest of your life
I'm sorry to just show up like this your
story has really inspired me your thesis
is about my rapists not just yours mine
too here all by yourself not anymore
take a baby
I can
meet a boy something like that for both
days never keep less brain
it's not your responsibility
they are not protecting us every one of
me detective I'm guessing they're a few
who never even tried why don't you start
there
you break the law is gonna be
consequences
I guess it depends on which law you pray
you